How concerned are you about the degree
to which the transgender Community now
seems to be the primary target of the
Maga movement I'm deeply concerned about
it I'm a vice chair of the quality
caucus so this is an issue I've been
very focused on on behalf of my
constituents and you're right just a
couple weeks ago Donald Trump did a
video from Mar-A-Lago the whole purpose
of which was to demonize the trans
Community basically to I guess show his
GOP Trump Maga base that he's even worse
on those issues than Ron DeSantis and
this is the the kind of primary that's
going on in the GOP which is who can
most dehumanize one of the most
vulnerable populations in the country
one that has a very high tragic a very
high suicide rate as well as being the
victim of a lot of violence directed at
the community by others